монета кузьмич відсоток над своїм новим
кліпом знімали майдан шик та екзост та
село почне шарму та на уралі всього
розірвані роблять пародію на російську
попсу глибоко відшкодував непотрібно
головне щоб підібрався їм юлії старий і
кава це михайлове кузьминих лише
відомому очей на якобу не
та кузьмич ми хочемо та щоб кліп guf
таким же висіла місць пара днів доки
дратуємо і чуємо і дітьми хан
чи пожвавився лижник шарму до цілого банку
нападали quit пармі буду але де до слави
та рик візитну
та студію та знімаємо майдан dji.com самий
тут юля то михайлов в литву зняв з
віпок з чорного виду мішей кліп пародію
на марокканську пісню дай картинка
на робочий квартал у нью-йорку
оригінальному кліпі лазня таку міць
надають ідилію російською
провінції в інтернеті є не
інтерпретація вже стала хітом
ви нігтиками мало що за деякими даними
придаток а слова а пізніше лось вас від 10
руки в тому у театральному куртку їх
його технікуму вже то дивани балуйся
пародіями на пупсу
яка крутилася а по радіо
було виявляєте хіт його шанують круті
тиц патчі на ю тубі пудово тис а ти нього
закопаєшся встигаєш цілими днями
доктор ціни просто так хоп і цілком тубі
на голову не ви назви снів підлоги
all оцініть чим ми просто приколі валу
сидіти біля будинку ми в сасш паспорт йому
доповіді лис вуса і працювала над собою і
над нашим і образом і над виступом і
образами над номерами для свого нас тут
нового кліпу
лазня та кузьмич прибрав і меншою
популярний кліп та складний хореографію
номер вигляд ставку на специфічній лишаєм
влади в шарм багато видів моя ніби їх
йому відповісти нас парочку і близько
санкції між Росією це за перебігом
ми проїжджаємо adobe дуся та нас лоджії
масі жити on сільське людей нами цьому
чим багатшим і тому й заради
куплета суді міста табу динкін ​​і в
домінікани
а в солим у гаю це своєї хмари забуду
і на зачат лити вас джоні санкції
відомо Юлія то Михайло розуміють що
для миша концерт так їх сили я книжник
куля мода москва звірява таку собі поле таку
душа до лайки дідус ми high-low
захопили дуету та роботі рекламу своєму
онуку його партнер ти на вуса asolo круто
круто розмножуються все вийшло арну всім
такого гарного так пишаємось ними заважаємо
осиним і що ви не в нашому селі знімає
такі кліпи навіть добрі наша солоха чп
розслабитися траха
Юля то Михайлу вірити що світло і США
занепалу про нижню армаду коливань і
знімуть sway доступною кліп про ідеальну
пару з російської глибинки
владна пробую ecu означають